lexington kentucky was mostly drugs and
guns um you know what i mean
weren't a lot of white i was one of the
few like white collar
uh criminals i was the only
counterfeiter there really well actually
there was one guy that was
counterfeiting chicks
okay
yeah yeah it's super
rare
for people to counterfeit
that amount of
bills right like you're you said in the
beginning of this that you were one of
like how many that have been
that have served federal time for doing
that well there's a lot of people that
have have served time for counterfeiting
but most in the secret service told me
this they they said they were like
you're the one these are the best bills
we've seen in 25 years really and he was
like the the majority of all their
counterfeiting cases are like you know
teenagers you know just photocopying you
know
and they don't look good and they
usually print a thousand dollars and
then get caught and then you know what i
mean
so the there's not a lot of like
professional counterfeiters out there
you know i only know of like two
you know matt was saying he he did the
12 years and he said i think he's only
met one or two and they that's what he
told me today he's like yeah i've met
two people ever that have done this and
they were probably just you know
photocopying bills you know what i mean
so like
it's hard to
to print money because the printers
recognize if you try to just print a
bill
the printer will recognize it and it
won't allow you to print you know i mean
so you can go into a photo copier
machine and just make a copy but then
they're going to look horrible you know
i mean so
i got around that by instead of scanning
the bill
because if you scan it it'll just put
some like penal code as to why you're
not allowed to scan bill money or
whatever so i'd take a
high resolution camera and take a photo
of it and then upload that photo and
then adjust you know go take it to adobe
photoshop the photo and edit everything
and layer it i layered it into three
different images
so when you went to print it you weren't
just printing one bill so the you know
the the printer couldn't recognize it
i'd print like just the background color
and then i'd print all the black work
over it and then i'd print the treasury
seal and serial numbers so it was
multiple different print printed each
layer separately yeah so the the printer
couldn't recognize that i was printing
money you know what i mean so it kind of
got around so how many layers total and
then so you would print how many layers
of this bible paper
uh well i mean layers is in like digital
right like on adobe i'd break it to
three different pictures you know right
one was just the background color
um the basically the front of the bills
had three different prints i'd print
three times just from the front of the
bill okay and then the back of the bill
i did two prints it just oh on the same
piece of paper yeah yeah got it okay so
like you're just printing a background
color first so it's just that beige
color of money it's just a solid
rectangle of that color and then you put
it back in the printer and print all the
ink you know the black stuff
and then put it through again and print
the treasury seal and serial numbers
so there was three prints for the front
two prints for the back and then one
print for the strip and the watermark
wow yeah so that was tricky i had to
like in order to print because the bible
paper is too too thin it'll jam up in
the printer i mean so you have to
tape it onto a piece of regular printer
paper so it's you know thick enough to
go through and be printed on right so
like i'd always me and my wife would
stay up all night just taping bible
paper to printing until we had a stack
like this you know i mean then the next
day we just run them all through and
print them out
um
you know so
it's hard it's hard to basically
counterfeit i mean most people when they
found out the bills were fake or or you
know knew what i was doing they'd
instantly be like i want you know sell
me a million dollars worth
and it's like you know each bill you're
literally handcrafting you know what i
mean
you're printed saying multiple prints
and then
you got to cut them out spray them with
you know if you spray too much gorilla
glue it'll [ __ ] up and be too thick if
you don't spray enough it'll
the pieces will separate so you know it
became a fine art of
you know spraying just the right amount
gluing them together making sure they're
lined up and then
spraying the lacquer a thick coat first
a thinner coat to give it that texture
you don't want to spray too much lacquer
because then it'll be too thick it won't
feel right so i mean it was a real like
fine-tooth process of uh
you know getting them just right but
after
doing it after about three four five
months i got to where you know it would
take me i could probably make like a
perfect counterfeit hundred and ten
minutes
really so
usually every day i'd make at least even
if nobody had any orders or anything i'd
make at least 25 bills 2500 bucks every
day and that was just like the money i
needed to survive you know i mean i was
spending at least 2 500 a day really
yeah on drugs well not all drugs but you
know i buy my drugs for the day
you know we had this nanny that was
working for us that you know and
hotel rooms out to dinners 2500 bucks a
day that's a lot you're like the tinder
swindler hey no
i haven't seen that i'd like to watch it
oh my god it's [ __ ] insane but you
got to think 2500 in counterfeit
hundreds like
in order to bust that
and convert it to real money you know
you're you're going and buying something
for ten dollars twenty dollars
so you know you buy some worthless [ __ ]
for twenty dollars you don't need just
to bust that bill just to bust it right
so out of that 2500 you know you're
you're really getting a bunch of [ __ ]
from walmart and whatever that you you
know may need you may not need or
whatever
but so you're probably getting you know
2 000 out of that 2 500 even even just
spending them at stores right so but
yeah 000 a day was kind of my standard
minimum amount of
has anybody uh ever since you got out
has anyone asked you for any uh like
custom
artwork or something or like uh no
custom artwork of currency i've had some
people want me to start countering you
know again yeah oh [ __ ] you can do
because they find out my story and find
out you know
and they want me to sell them but you
should break make more and sell but you
know what have you uh do you still like
run in the same circles like have the
same talk to the same people or has it
been like difficult to kind of like like
recalibrate your life since you got out
yeah i mean
i uh yeah no i'm i'm sober now i've been
sober for like two years now so i don't
really associate with
any of those people anymore it was
mostly just like drug dealers and you
know
so do you think you would have got i
mean you probably wouldn't got so if you
didn't go to prison right probably not
probably not i i mean honestly it it
definitely
helped you know all around is for the
best you know i mean i was kind of
living a crazy life yeah
for a long time so
has it been hard to adjust since you've
gotten out like like has it been
difficult to like find a place to live
to get work and like what's that been
like well i i just got out like three
months ago so did you really yeah um but
luckily i i found a good job man
it's working at a print shop so
[Laughter]
i uh you know and i was honest with them
up front i told them like listen i'm on
you know supervised release right for
counterfeiting and you know they're
they're all cool guys where i work so i
mean obviously your skill with like
graphic design photoshop and that kind
of [ __ ] right do they respect that and
be like wow you can actually like apply
that to something
and i've been in that that trade like i
was in the sign business before so signs
and graphics are all pretty related you
know what i mean so i've worked at a
couple print shops vinyl shops
beforehand so i've got experience in it
on top of the you know illegal
experience but
um but yeah they were you know they
hired me and they're they're really cool
understanding if i have to you know miss
work to go to probation or whatever yeah
they're all good man i really lucked out
with that job